Henry Blackburn I want you guys to
record this and run with this
uh Henry Blackburn is a good player who
played a phenomenal game he made a
tremendous uh hit on Travers on the
sideline you could call it dirty you
could call it he was just playing the
game of football but whatever it was it
does not constitute that he should be
receiving death threats that that's this
is still a young man trying to make it
in life a guy that's trying to live his
dream and hopefully graduate with honors
or degree uh committed to Excellence and
go to the NFL he does not deserve a
death threat over a game at the end of
the day this is a game someone must win
someone must lose everybody continues
their life the next day very unfortunate
I'm sadden if there's any of our fans
that's on the other side of those
threats I would hope and pray not but
that kid was just playing the best of
his ability and he made a mistake so I
forgive him see you our team forgive him
um Travis is he's forgiven him let's
move on but that kid does not deserve
that